okie dokie branimir branimir maximovich
yeah plating quite a bit recent videos
oh it's new he never played that before
I think against me okay okay just is not
castle I wonder is that a good idea not
canceling their for that such a long
time if for maybe check
and laughs I don't believe in that
really don't 94 six is this some may
have g3 as well okay I can take him
Queen edge for g3 here yeah so how do I
play I mean he's not he's not
threatening anything at the moment I
don't see at least what he threatens
let's go here for
just trying to use this rock the rookie
s not playing only one and sometimes
look a three years and a DM well not in
many cases admittedly okay so some way
to put the bishop out a 5 Queen a 4 is
probably nonsense
okay let's go there one idea is simply
five so that after Bishop f3 I can take
with the Queen
I wonder if I'm blundering something on
the back Ranga my back rank is weak
really is really is i don't i don't see
it at the moment
training queens looks wrong so playing
this my bloody bishop on c 1 f 5 would
be nice to get an f5 Bishop f5 I can't
play those two moves I'm I'm just
winning i guess but difficult tick with
the pawn I thought isn't that strong
temple and then here to attack c5 I mean
his King is not secure absolutely not
my route 25 maybe Brooksie one
now it's still mean if King is not safe
but it's it's still it's not falling
apart in a moment I thought here maybe
for her looks is seven I don't get my
queen involved easily this is a problem
yeah I thought Queenie for may be here
on rook rook c7 first Queenie for
Queenie form yeah let's do that sits an
awkward move to him to meet and see
cannot really take what you can take
that idiot idiot idiot you can just do
that a stupid very bad I totally
overlooked that and now we can take that
check these six and it's ok that was a
spot that oh what a shame that was
unsuccessful cover that's cover the
second rank
hmm what a shame with this open qingdao
there's certainly i think that certainly
were some chances i've been strange if
not really
okay let's bring the king of field still
quite comfortable you this end game f6
son f6 is a month and I have root g5 now
that you cannot oppose this really
yeah i think this rook endgame if he
trades on c5 is very good i have the
activity and and control over the sea
file so let's see him check here first
or we'll get six or i can also do this
g5 check their time morning of six
that's also quite good can i play for
mate I'm Jack this is much easier just
this antique take him so no the pawns
one yep that's okay
I a text there didn't really see that he
both takes it and covers a chain but II
pawn is too strong I have 20 seconds I
didn't really realize that the f porn is
shielding from chicks oh really black
resigns yeah a shame that I've better
played this Queenie foam I completely
overlooked that he can just take the six
I really should keep the Queen's on
because of his farm more critical King
position I Roxy seven in fact is winning
the game Jack hey did I couldn't believe
that this is kind of situation here so
something like this and then Quincy one
yeah that's strong for Quincy six yeah
and and that's it yes no no defense this
is even a clean made checkmate jam that
was interesting I don't know why he just
laid without castling and went for this
this this is a check Nyjah form I was I
was briefly wondering about this but I
have G 3m this keeps a things together a
form before Queen back
523 21 yeah that's interesting but now I
don't think this is a great idea
allowing me this oh the computer is
completely cool King b7 yeah this is
probably not going to end well with the
age for an open-air like us better him
but he went back and now everything is
cool why does much better I just had a
blackout with Queenie phone also quite
lucky that he hidden made some some
second rate moves there to give me a
group d to immediately was strong rapid
yeah I'm getting controlling the other a
five points weekend ultimately led to
his defeat in the rook endgame okay well
thanks for watching